why did you feel you need to tell this
personal story what why was it so
important to you because I knew that I
needed to learn how to forgive that's
that's basically as a as simple as it as
it as it as can be
really because like my I think for the
majority of my adult life I've harbored
lots of like really mean unfair feelings
against my brother and it's really only
been I think really actually it's it's
kind of timed up perfectly with the
making of this film because now like for
instance before the movie we rarely ever
talked and I probably saw my brother
maybe like once a year maybe maybe and
that was on holidays and I was just for
the free food it's always for and and I
I knew that I wanted to try to forgive
him and I wanted to also try to forgive
myself for not forgiving him it's like
this weird inception like mind trick but
basically I I came out of film school
and I was like I really want to make a
feature what's the most potent topic I
can make a feature about in my life and
I tried to write I wrote all these other
scripts but I realized I was mostly
running away from wanting to talk about
my brother and so the whole thing was
originally designed because like what I
wanted to happen and this would have
been so great it was I I get a kick out
of it but what what was supposed to
happen is I was gonna write a script and
I was gonna play myself in the script
and my brother was gonna play himself
and because I wrote it I could make him
say things to me and I could say things
to him and together throughout this
process we could learn to forgive each
other and hopefully maybe salvage a
little bit of a relationship out of it
that was the that was the whole point
and what was what was crazy is almost
like down to the to the to the day like
I started writing the script and I was
talking to my brother and my brother and
I for the first time started talking
about
I would ask him like hey so why did you
used to do that growing up or why were
you never here what what were you doing
and he kind of opened up to me and he
would start telling me these things I
would take those things and kind of
craft them into a character and to the
script and things like that and
throughout the writing process we talked
more than we'd ever talked before and
almost like clockwork the day that I
finished the script I picked up the
phone to call him and his number was
disconnected and I was like what's going
on and so I called my mom and my mom was
like oh you haven't heard he went on the
run from the police and so he just
disappeared and so I was like oh man
okay Wow
and it was weird because I kind of knew
it would happen like I knew that uh
stalking consistently wasn't something
it was probably gonna continue to happen
at this point in our in our relationship
and before I knew it he was gone and so
we went and made the movie kind of in a
more I don't wanna say legit cuz it's
like extremely micro-budget but uh but
we you know hired actors and like
something was gonna be a thing and
before that I was just gonna be
basically me and him and like a DP and
that's it that's what that was what the
whole thing was designed to do and what
was wild though is like after we
finished it was almost like it was
almost like we almost synced up in this
weird way like we weren't in connection
but like when when our movie got into
post-production like at one point all of
our financing fell through and so I was
doing post just by myself it was like me
and one of my friends doing post and so
the movie like you know went to a crawl
and while that happened like that while
that happened like I found out my
brother was he got in caught anyone to
prison and so it's weird cuz I felt like
I was trapped in post when my brother
was trapped in prison that's that's what
it felt like and then the craziest thing
happened at one point like the finance
so the financial end got taken care of
in terms of posts and then suddenly
things sped up again and around that
time my brother got released early from
prison on a work release program and so
he
he basically got out of prison and then
he was sort of in this sort of
incubating period where all he had to do
was was he had to get a job and he had
to report to certain parole officers and
things like that and so like we I
finished the movie almost exactly around
the time he got out of out of prison and
what was fascinating is like because he
had gone through this really rough
experience and I've gone through a
creatively rough experience we both kind
of met up again and like our
relationship kind of picked up right
right where it left off and it was
beautiful and he saw the movie and he
saw himself in the movie and saw how I
felt about him in the movie in like we
cried about it and like and since then
this is like what seven months later we
text every day we call each other every
other day and we talk frequently and my
brother now like he's completely turned
his life around he's got a it's got a
great job and you know he's being a
father to his children and it's a
beautiful thing and I really do think
that that our whole family coming
together to tell the story of that is my
future then there was Joe I think that
truly healed my family and I can I can
say that unequivocally like I mean it
totally brought my family together in a
beautiful way and so I I do know at
least the power of movies to at least
heal my family and that's a real thing
and that was a very beautiful thing that
I don't think could have been planned it
just happened sort of serendipitously
and it was beautiful and so I do know
like first hand that that's why I tell
stories I tell them to heal I know you
just you said you screen the film at the
Arkansas cinema Society and was your
brother there he was it was amazing
because it what we weren't sure if he
was gonna be able to make it he actually
had to get like you know permission to
actually show up and do it but he was
there he was in the second row and
that it wasn't the first time he had
seen it because we watched it we watched
it together before that but he was there
and it was it was amazing because he was
laughing almost harder than anyone else
was laughing in the movie which was
great and then afterwards like it was
amazing because the REA Grady who's the
actor that plays my brother who was
phenomenal in the movie got to meet my
actual brother and it was an amazing
experience seeing both of them together
because like I cast Rea Grady because
the essence of Rea Grady reminded me
more of my brother than any other human
being I'd ever met in my whole life and
so to see both of them together was
mind-blowing it was awesome it was
incredible and they were like kindred
spirits
they were like joking and and like they
had always been friends
it was amazing it's a really cool
experience
you